And turkey tail mushrooms be taken by someone who is allergic to mushrooms.
I didn't know if it was from a different component of the mushrooms that was a problem.
So, if your allergic to sooms, my first question would be how do you know your allergic to mushrooms?
Well, I break out when I eat mushrooms, so I can't eat mushrooms or I get an anaphylactic shock
when I have eat mushrooms. Well, if you have anaphylaxis from eating mushrooms and I would stay away
from any mushroom products whatsoever because you have an IgE reaction.
If you break out or you get a tummy ache when you eat mushrooms or some doctor tested you with
kinesiology or you did an IgE, IgG food panel test at one point in time and you came up positive
for mushrooms that you've been eliminated mushrooms from that, from those scenarios,
I would say, no, go ahead and take the medicinal mushroom products.
Your IgE antibody tests, if you had them done in the past and that showed positive for mushrooms,
that can change, you know, within a couple of months of you eliminated mushrooms. So,
many times people will do a food sensitivity panel and it would become positive in something so
that they'll stay off of it the rest of their life. My mother-in-law was like that. I remember she
said she can't eat walnuts. Why can't you eat walnuts? Because the doctor told her when she was
like 15 that she couldn't eat walnuts and now she's 70 years old and she still not had a walnut.
Well, the chance that you're sensitive to walnuts, you know, even after a few months of
stop eating walnuts is pretty slim to zero. So, but she was very much a rule follower and she followed
that rule even though I think foolishly to her demise because she didn't get to enjoy walnuts.
There was many other things that she stayed away from because some doctor told her when she was in
her teens that she was allergic to something. Food sensitivities can come and go, especially if you
stay off that food and more importantly, if you're talking, there's a difference between an IGE
reaction, food sensitivity like a peanut allergy, IGE reaction, and a food sensitivity where you react
to a food IGE sensitivity. Gluten would probably be the only exception of that. People can be off
gluten 100% for 10 years and you still do food panel on them and they still show positive antibodies.
So, I hope that helps that question.